hi there steve here today this video i'm
going to talk about politics and unless
i get a tremendously negative response
i'm going to continue to do the odd
video on politics because i enjoy doing
it and i enjoy the reaction that i get
and the response and exchange of
positions i don't expect to persuade
anyone of my views
uh i'm very realistic i don't think that
other people should expect to persuade
anyone of their views that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't exchange
views it stimulates the mind at the very
least it stimulates you to defend your
own views and quite possibly it opens
you up to some other perspectives so i'm
going to talk about the situation in
ukraine
and they're going to start with a very
interesting video that i saw
i guess it's not two evenings ago where
on this
ukrainian news opinion program called
shuster live where the host actually
speaks russian most of the people on the
program speak ukrainian but a lot of
them also speak russian and as i've said
before it seems that in ukraine
ukrainian russian
doesn't seem to bother anyone
in reality although the issue of
language is very political there in fact
people
seem to be able to communicate quite
well
uh
one person speaking ukrainian the other
person speaking russian
so dobkin is interviewed by schuster
the first very interesting thing is that
dobkin who is the former mayor i believe
of kharkov the second largest city in
ukraine
um i don't know that he was the governor
there but he was certainly the mayor of
harkov
and in fact in my little description
thing i'm going to put a link to a
rather amusing
video of him getting ready to make some
kind of a video presentation to the good
citizens of kharkov
so the interesting thing is that dobkin
is under house arrest in ukraine
and why is he under house arrest
according to what either schuster or
dobkin said in the interview it's
because he said quote we shouldn't be
afraid of the word
federalism
or federalization or federalism
and that was considered a separatist
statement and therefore he was put under
house arrest so my immediate reaction as
a canadian is to say like what
uh
canada is a federation
not only is canada a federation
but one of the provinces has been ruled
for a good part of the last 35 years by
a separatist government and that the
separatist government on two occasions
has organized a referendum on separation
and while there were detailed rules
about how much advertising for the yes
and the no and stuff like that which our
federal government tried to circumvent
and that created a big scandal
nevertheless uh there have been two
referenda and so the government the
separatist government of quebec
regularly participates in meetings with
the other
provincial premiers in canada so the
word federalist
in a quebec content context means
someone who is pro the central
government and a separatist is someone
who is who wants to separate but he's
still not a criminal
but in ukraine the word federalist is
almost
criminal and the word separatist is like
traitor
so that comes as a bit of a shock
initially
then there was another portion of the
discussion where dobkins said
you know we've lost
crimea we should stop saying we're gonna
get it back because we can't just get it
back
however
what happened there is that those people
decided
to become russian
so if we want them back we have to
persuade those people to want to become
ukrainian again
um
when i hear that i say to myself so
there's an issue here of persuading
people
whether they want to be this or that
that seems to open up
pandora's box in terms of trying to
persuade
citizens of eastern or southern ukraine
to become
russian or ukrainian
in other words if it's a matter of of
constantly trying to persuade people
where they belong
uh that opens opportunities
for
um more referenda
not to mention the fact that quite
obviously in russia you are not allowed
to have a referendum on independence let
alone joining another country so that uh
however much persuading dobkin and other
ukrainians might try to do there's no
way they could influence the future of
crimea
but it raises another interesting point
and that is that
in what we see happening in ukraine
uh what i see is it's it's a conflict of
nationalism
and i know there was a book written
about
you know the uh
what is it the uh conflict of
civilizations or the i can't remember
what word was used that there's going to
be this clash of civilizations but what
we're seeing really is
is uh particularly in former communist
countries we're seeing a renewal of
nationalism which is creating all kinds
of tensions
we had the uh
the sort of uh gentle separation in
czechoslovakia where the czechs and
slovaks went their own way and they're
now as friendly or more friendly with
each other than they've ever been but we
also had yugoslavia
so their nationalisms were suppressed
all of a sudden the lid was taken off
and we had the horrible
sort of bloodshed
now we see russia
as the sort of soviet you know the
internationalism of the communists and
the soviets has been removed now the
russians are discovering their national
identity their nationalism
and their nationalism as as ethnic
russians and this poses very interesting
questions because in russia
the country in fact is consists of many
different
nationalities ethnic groups people in
the caucasus the tatars and others
but the message in russia is one very
much of the sort of russian spirit
russian soul russian culture russian
language russian orthodox russian church
so their nationalism is being built
around the sort of ethnic russian thing
and so there you have that sort of
increasingly strident nationalism in
russia and so they look around and they
say you know what's the matter with us
we got
brothers and sisters russians living in
uh ukraine latvia
uh you know kazakhstan whatever estonia
we gotta look after those people because
that's our nation that's this whole
nationalism thing which was dormant for
so long is now becoming more powerful
so and then you have in the ukraine
you have
the nationalism of the ukrainian
speaking largely ukrainian-speaking
western central ukrainians
where
the language becomes a sign of their
national identity and then you have the
people in the east and south
of the ukraine
some of whom are russians who moved
there under the soviet union when they
were building up the industrial base
there
some of whom uh i mean personally
there's probably so much intermarriage
and so many of them simply speak russian
that uh even people with ukrainian names
who speak russian culturally russian i
don't see how you can distinguish those
people from
someone who for two or three generations
has lived in in ukraine speaks russian
and whose family originally came from
russia and i gather there's a lot of
family connections across the border
cultural connections and so forth so if
it turns out and i don't know this but
if it turns out that those in the
western ukraine have a sense of their
nationalism which is built around
different history being under
poland the polish lithuanian whatever
kingdom being under the austro-hungarian
empire being under poland
uh therefore more oriented towards the
west
and if the those in the east were under
the czars or under the soviet union
uh are culturally connected to the
russian world
if russian nationalism is rising
then how attractive is that to those
russian speakers or russian ethnic
people cultural russians who live in the
east and south probably quite attractive
um so and if i look at the history of
ukraine it seems that every five years
either the eastern and southern
ukrainians vote in their party
of
people who
corrupt leaders who basically skim large
amounts of money out of the system and
then every the other uh period they get
people from the west to do the same
equally disorganized equally um
you know ineffective and equally corrupt
so uh it seems as if there's a constant
see-sawing between the east and the west
so what i don't know is how strong is
the feeling of of ukrainian-ness
in the
in the east and south and of course
these kinds of feelings of identity can
change
uh again having studied czech
uh german speakers
were
30 of the population of czechoslovakia
between the wars
and i gather for an initial 15 years or
so
they were quite happy to participate
in czech or czechoslovakian political
life complaining that they didn't get
enough language rights complaining about
x y and z but still participating in the
government but then as german
nationalism grew
and with a lot of propaganda beamed at
them from
hitler's germany more and more of these
columns to dating
wanted to be part of germany now to be
fair
at the end of the first world war
the german speakers in the
austro-hungarian empire that is the
sudan germans the austrians
the people in in what's known as alto
adige
tyrol
in what is now italy but they're german
speakers they all wanted to be part of
the same country and they weren't
allowed to do that
because the allies wanted to weaken
germany and so they lived separately
so all of a sudden germany is on the
rise
and stirs up these people and now these
people are very unhappy and they have to
be part of germany and so germany uses
all of this as justification for what
led up to the munich agreement
and they're also german speakers in
poland so germany now this
nationalist germany
feels they have a right and an
obligation to look after their brothers
and sisters who obviously are being
maltreated
in these other countries and so this now
is a similar scenario to what we're
seeing in ukraine you have on the one
hand the western ukrainians who had a
great time there they overthrew
um yanukovych
but they installed therefore a
government that is
more
dominated by western ukrainians not
exclusively but mostly
and so how does that make the eastern eu
or southern ukrainians feel and i also
know from looking at opinion polls that
historically the western ukrainians are
more in favor of
joining the common mar the european
union and the eastern and southern
ukrainians
not surprisingly are more in favor of
joining what's called the customs union
and aligning themselves with russia so
they sit there and they say oh the
western guys have taken over now so now
whereas
say a year or two years ago opinion
polls in eastern and southern ukraine
and crimea showed lukewarm interest in
joining russia because after all their
guy was in power
yanukovych but once their guy is no
longer in power and you have these other
guys maybe now they're not so keen on
being in ukraine they're more keen on
joining russia and if you add into that
the tremendously aggressive propaganda
barrage from russia telling them that
they're under attack and they're all
going to be shot up and they're all
fascists and kiev all of which is
essentially i would call it false
because the degree of of danger in
ukraine
of insecurity is even with the latest
shooting in kiev is probably less than
what it is in russia again looking at my
statistics on the internet the crime
rate the murder rate in ukraine
historically is like a half to a third
of what it is in russia and when you add
in the problems the russians have with
terrorists from the caucasus and so
forth and so on even with the right
sector uh odd guy uh shooting people up
it makes the headlines but in fact
people are not in any great danger in
ukraine despite the propaganda barrage
from the russians also
the russians make a big point of how
illegitimate you know the new government
is because
yanukovych was elected but hitler was
elected
and over the last you know the two three
years of his term i mean there's a
reason why
we had these demonstrations in in
ukraine uh yanukovych created conditions
where a lot of people were unhappy and
my understanding is
a lot of people demonstrating in the
maidan the freedom demonstrators were
not necessarily
all committed to joining the european
union a lot of it had to do with their
dissatisfaction with the government
corrupt it had been increasingly
restricting
uh you know the press and the media it
put
this uh political opponent timoshenko in
jail
uh so the i mean to the extent that
yanukovych was in power he's responsible
for the events of the maidan they
happened under his watch
and i think the news will come out that
a lot of the brutality and the sniper
activity and so forth were also directed
by yanukovych so the fact that someone
was elected doesn't mean that
that and if that elected person is
continuing to
to abuse
their position
then there may very well be a popular
uprising
subsequent to that
the uh a majority of the members of the
uh of the uh verhovna radar the the
parliament in fact
uh agreed to work together to form this
new government
a new government which in my opinion
should have been some kind of a
coalition government and i think that
was initially proposed and i think that
the
the western ukrainians who dominate this
new government are far too strident in
insisting on their agenda you know the
first thing they tried to do was change
the language laws which they have to you
know
give away on
uh and you know in in their comments
about russia they're so
strident
um you know i think
torchino the president said that uh
crimea will become russia's afghanistan
and putin's afghanistan and stuff like
this there's just a lot of
unnecessary aggravation there but
fundamentally to me
it's an issue of of the clash of
nationalisms and the big question to me
is
where is the allegiance of the people in
the eastern and southern ukraine
and the unfortunate thing is that
because those people are basically
plugged into the
russian media they are being totally
bombarded with
the russian
uh you know propaganda message
and i think the government in kiev
should be thinking about how they can
reach out to and persuade those people
that they'll be better off in ukraine
rather than
being stridently you know anti-putin
anti-russia and all the rest of it
they've kind of somehow and i think in
that sense i read again in the ukrainian
because i'm trying to read ukrainian in
the ukrainian newspaper online that
they're they've taken sort of uh
photo displays of the maidan to various
cities in eastern ukraine and they're
trying to explain to them
why they think that changes that that
that they're hoping to bring about
will improve
living conditions uh throughout ukraine
because after all i am sure that the
ukrainians everywhere would like to
live better earn more money not have
politicians that that build that siphon
off millions and billions of dollars and
build
extravagant mansions and and so forth
they would like to be governed better
and they would like to live
probably
even though the allegiance in the east
may be more towards a russian eurasian
community they would like to live
under the same conditions and
institutions as exist in western europe
without necessarily having to ally
themselves uh with western europe so
my take on all of this is that we're
talking about a clash of nationalisms
nationalisms that were kind of kept
under the lid
during the soviet period and and by the
way it's not just ukraine if you go to
latvia i haven't been to estonia but in
latvia
the latvians now have this sense that
their
little group of one and a half million
people uh is threatened
because there's 40 russians there
can those russian speakers buy into the
latvian national agenda or are they a
perennial sort of
outpost of the russian diaspora a
potential fifth column
that's a big concern especially with a
strident russian nationalism which is
bound to infect
russians living over the border in
latvia and so these are all very
interesting questions of how much
you know the latvians would like to
convert all those russians into latvians
uh is that going to happen i don't know
so those are some of the issues um i see
these as a canadian you know as very
interesting because
my attitude here in canada where we
receive a lot of immigrants is
um
i would like those people to assimilate
i would like them and that has typically
been the case in the past that whether
they come from the ukraine and the
ukrainians
initially were the big promoters of
multiculturalism and getting government
funding for ukrainian language programs
and you know money for them to paint
easter eggs and dance in their national
costumes and stuff which i think they
should do
on their own ticket and it's not
something that i think the canadian
government should promote uh we
shouldn't prevent them obviously they do
what they want and i don't even think we
should force we shouldn't force
assimilate people but we should
encourage people to feel that
whoever their neighbor is whether
they're from china afghanistan portugal
you know japan doesn't matter they're
canadian so that there is a sense of
solidarity and you're building up a
sense of identity and identity is a
subjective thing and it moves and
changes depending on a lot of
circumstances and i think that's also
going to be an issue in the ukraine
is is where is the identity of those
people in in eastern ukraine and quite
frankly i don't know i don't know what
it is but hopefully
that
these kinds of issues can be resolved in
a peaceful way
rather than
the kind of
precedent that we have
uh in the 1930s so there's my little
ramble just to get started and i look
forward to opinions and ideas and hope
to do more of these bye for now